[Music]
[Music]
hey guys pete here can you believe that
there are only two more episodes of
better call saul left today i'll be
previewing what we might expect to see
in episode 12 which is titled waterworks
the teaser that aired mid-credit seems
so connected to what happened at the end
of episode 11 that it's almost
suspicious most of what we've gotten in
that department after the mid-season
break has been on a scale from
mysterious to misleading so we'll look
at some alternative ideas of what might
be going on there there are no promo
photos this week and that and a lot of
context clues lead me to believe my
theory about seeing some kim this week
is probably correct i've been racking my
brain since we did the live stream on
how that might work so i'll be giving
you an update on that as well if any of
what i just mentioned sounds like
spoilers to you then this is officially
your chance to leave and with that out
of the way let's get into it
series co-creator vince gilligan will do
something he's never done before this
week write and direct an episode of
better call saul he did do this on
breaking bad of course he was the
creator and showrunner of that series
and he co-wrote and directed a few
episodes of the prequel including the
pilot that he directed and co-wrote with
show runner peter gould but this is the
first time that he has both credits for
bcs talk about the end of an era i guess
if you've been saving up an ernest bravo
vince this will be your week to unleash
it waterworks has a short and vague
description that reads the stakes are
raised when a discovery is made as has
been the case with most of the second
half of the season there's no telling
exactly what this is referring to if you
think about gene he has just broken into
the home of the mark that he learned had
cancer a lot of people think he might
discover his dead body due to medication
interactions remember part of the scam
involves knocking the person out with
barbiturates so they can steal their
identities while they sleep i suppose if
those reacted with his cancer meds then
that would raise the stakes there's a
much repeated theory that i saw in the
comments in my last video that gene will
find him as he's dying similar to how
walt found jane and then he'll have to
make a decision of whether he saves him
or just goes on with the robbery while
this would put him in an interesting
situation i'm not sure that's where
things are heading part of that is
related to a new york times interview
that i'll come back to but be warned
that just serves to make things more
confusing rather than clearing anything
up let's talk about the teaser where at
least what's happening is pretty
straightforward two police officers have
arrived at a home and they exit their
car unlike the previous teasers we don't
get a line of dialogue from gene or any
other character instead we just hear the
police radio saying that backup is on
route and for the officers to proceed
with caution apparently a reddit user
discovered that the police radio was
recycled from a scene from season five
so i wouldn't think too hard about it
it's clear they're responding to a call
and i guess the important questions are
is this the house gene just broke into
and is he still inside i'm guessing the
marketing department would like for us
to believe that but how would that
actually play out
the street looks like it could be the
same as where jeff dropped him off and
one thing that stands out is that one of
the officers is putting his hand on his
gun at the end we know that a break-in
occurred at the cancer man's house and
maybe they just aren't sure if there's
someone still inside gene told jeff to
come pick him up in 20 minutes what type
of scenario would see the police get
there before he does or what would keep
gene inside for longer than that you
could go in a lot of different
directions trying to answer these
questions which i definitely have but
either way it doesn't feel like he would
actually be caught here they made a
point of showing marion seeing him
arrive late at night so it's clear that
she has an idea that something's going
on i'm not sure why you would set that
up if he were just going to get arrested
after he leaves also she's got that
computer that he showed her how to use
if she were to make a discovery about
who he really is i would say that that
would also raise the stakes i also think
that we've seen several points where his
charm isn't working as well as he thinks
it is and that hints again that she
knows more than what she's letting on
you had him stumble with the question
about nippy when he forgot about his own
lie in the first episode she was in
there was the reaction she had when he
took jeff outside to have their drinks
and so by the time that she sees him
coming back to the house late at night
she probably has some suspicions about
him in a roundabout way this would feel
like it was justice for irene landry
that was one of his most despicable acts
where he used this same charm that is so
effective on the elderly and that makes
the prospects of him underestimating
marian and her turning things around all
the more tantalizing again you could go
in a lot of different directions to try
to make that make sense and just to
complicate things further there was this
new york times article that came out
before the season started in that bob
odenkirk was being interviewed while he
was filming this episode with vince
gilligan it describes him sneaking
around someone's home picking up
different items which would make sense
for what happened at the end of episode
11. the problem is that one of the shots
they describe has jean looking down from
a balcony and the cancer guy appears to
live in a single level ranch-style house
that would seem to indicate that he's
still out there breaking into other
houses after what happened with him i
guess if i was pressed to make a general
prediction i would say that i think he
gets out of the break-in situation only
to learn that he has an even bigger
problem to deal with the articles writer
also describes a cat and mouse game
going on with a different character
inside this house while he's drinking a
glass of liquor so as i mentioned before
it's more confusing than anything else
if you think about the ending of the
last episode
and the way they cut it together with
him approaching walt's school you're
watching two decisions that alter the
trajectory of his life in both cases he
does something he shouldn't do because
he can't help himself if we look at his
situation as an addiction he's in the
height of it in the breaking bad
timeline and in relapse in omaha we know
the phone call is the event that set off
his most recent episode and my gut
reaction when i was watching the episode
for the first time was that they were
keeping the contents of that from us so
they could reveal it later it just
didn't really make sense for them to do
that otherwise and tom schnauz did
confirm that we would hear the details
of this call in a future episode to the
hollywood reporter if you go looking
you'll find several people who cleaned
up this audio and while there's some
debate on exactly what's being said the
one thing they all agree on is that he's
talking to kim and that he addresses her
by name the first thing i thought about
was that they were doing the same thing
they did with nachos call to mike in
episode 602. in the next episode we got
to see the call from his perspective and
i think we'll get the same thing here
with kim this is not some kind of far
out idea i'm definitely not alone in
this thinking it seems to be popular to
the point that it's almost inevitable
the episode's title waterworks will
certainly have more than one
interpretation but there's an obvious
connection to her working at a sprinkler
company i don't think it's a question of
if kim will appear but more of how much
of her life will get to see that will
depend on her situation and i think
that's the most interesting part of this
if she's just been living her life
without incident since she made the
decision to leave the marriage behind i
suppose we wouldn't need a lot to
explain that things are basically the
same show some scenes with her day to
day maybe even do another split screen
montage and we know enough about the
character to piece things together i got
the impression that she was shifting the
responsibility and on some level the
blame to herself in their last
conversation and i don't think that
bodes well for an easy transition to a
happy carefree life she may have taken a
page out of howard's book though and
actually dealt with her problems
depending on where she's at in that
journey or if she's on it at all would
dictate how much we'd need to see to
understand what's going on with her
based on jean's reaction to that call
you could make that work she knows what
happened she told him to take care of
the situation and turn himself in and
then told him not to contact her could
that work as a satisfying ending i mean
i guess on some level jimmy might think
that she can save him or that getting
back together would take him out of the
spiral he's currently in he would be
wrong but maybe being deprived of that
connection would force him to go in one
direction or the other from what we've
seen lately that would probably be
complete self-destruction that's kind of
where we're at but i suppose it's
possible that he tries to reach out
again and through that realizes that
there really is no chance and that is
what's difficult for someone who cares
about somebody who is spiraling an
addiction but there's not much you can
do when the person is engaged in the
compulsion her doing what she thought
was right would be an ending for the
character but i'm expecting it to get
more complicated than that we also need
to learn if they've been in contact
since she's left my initial thinking was
that if he knew where she worked then
they must have been in contact at some
point in the six years since she left
they were married so it could be as
simple as them needing to get a divorce
not knowing if that's true or how things
went down makes it hard to imagine what
their ending will be and so i don't see
how we don't have a decent amount of her
life in the upcoming episode and that's
not even to mention the dramatic effect
of bringing her back after being gone
for two episodes or the possibility of
having her showing up without the
ponytail at the end of the last
installment things felt darker which
makes it seem like we might be running
out of road for him to redeem himself
even a little bit it's also not clear
where the inspiration could come from i
think marion will play a role in the
current scamming coming to an end and
beyond her and jeff who else is left
maybe the cancer man they spent some
time letting us get to know him and he
turned out to be quite sympathetic could
he see past this mask and in his
position with nothing to lose get
through to jimmy i keep going back to
the last episode and wondering about
what they were trying to tell us as far
as his current situation we saw a lot of
detail about the progression of his
scams the slippery slope that will
always lead back to him being saul
goodman or maybe worse and him not being
able to stop in relation to walt and
jesse's appearance we learned that saul
could have left them alone and got solid
advice from mike to do so but ignored it
there's an added layer there of mike not
being able to take his own advice later
on in the story but i don't suppose
that's very important for what we're
talking about right now what stands out
is that him making the decision led to
some discussion about whether saul was
responsible for walter white's rise to
power and from my perspective i feel
that that underestimates what a force of
nature that character is what's more
interesting i think is how jimmy feels
about it because going in i felt that if
they were gonna bring these two back for
that to work it should be more about him
in our live stream discussion on tuesday
we talked about this and two things
stuck with me first gill pointed out
that from saul's perspective he could
believe that he was responsible for the
carnage that walter white left in his
path the second was courtney bringing up
all the frankenstein references and i've
seen some other interesting takes on
that in the past couple of days as well
a simple explanation of what that story
is about is that victor with a c
frankenstein creates a man from pieces
of corpses and brings a brand new
creature to life initially it had good
intentions and sought affection but
everyone it met was afraid of him
because of course he was a bunch of
different pieces of bodies put together
and brought back to life it's kind of
terrifying he eventually turns on the
doctor who never took responsibility for
what he created with those things in
mind and having no idea how kim might
find herself compelled to intervene in
the current situation i wonder if the
same way jimmy thinks he created a
monster in walt kim might think she
created a monster in seoul her
encouraging his transformation was a big
part of the beginning of this season i
imagine there would have to be some
other steps that we haven't seen maybe
she knew what he was up to during the
events of breaking bad or maybe
something related to the phone call as
mentioned before i do think we'll see
that from her perspective in this
episode but either way i think this
makes more sense than her coming out of
retirement to defend him in court or
just deciding to rescue him based on
their past relationship at the very
least it's a way in and those seem to be
in short supply at the end of episode
611. maybe it's just me trying to cope
with the reality that's being laid out
in front of me but i defer back to peter
gould's assessment of how the two main
characters of the series are different
he said if there were a simple way to
distinguish the two characters i think
walt wants to be respected and feared
and jimmy i think really wants everyone
to like him he wants love and i think
that starting point has made his decline
much more tragic and i think it's
natural to want to see some type of
redemption although gould did add that
he goes about it in all kinds of strange
ways and i can't argue with that i've
seen some people bringing back the chuck
was right all along argument which i
think overlooks his complicity and
making his own prophecy come true i
wouldn't say chuck was responsible for
saul any more than i would say that he's
responsible for walter white but i think
it's interesting to think about why one
brother is a lot more sympathetic than
the other while chuck was mentally ill
and that's a big part of what was
happening with him during the series he
was also always convinced that his
brother was beyond redemption like
walter he never saw what he was doing
was wrong and in the end he was just
bitter that he didn't win that's part of
why a crash and burn finale would be
depressing thinking that jimmy
internalized that and went out thinking
chuck was right about him this is a
universe that likes to explore the
consequences of actions though we only
have two more episodes to go and i think
we need to find out how kim fits into
this ending so yeah bring that on and i
think that's a great place to leave
things let me know in the comments what
you're expecting to see there are two
more scenes with walt and jesse
appearing separately according to brian
cranston so what are you hoping to see
with those please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon